The Joe Rogan Experience what'd you
think of what do you think of all his
stuff
I don't know what's happening right like
what is what really happened and why is
why is Romania going after him are they
being pressured by someone else to do
this like what what is the reason why
they're doing it and what do they have
on him I don't know yeah well that to me
is the right answer it
how could nobody knows a lot of people
are acting like they know if you go read
well they want him which is crazy they
want him to go down and they want him he
represents something he represents toxic
masculinity well he is he he is sort of
toxic I mean he says crazy he sees his
car collection as investigation
continues the one thing I don't get
about this well I do get I understand
people are actually like want the
charges to be true which is crazy
because that would mean a lot of bad
[ __ ] to what happened to a lot of bad
people yeah I would rather the charges
be incorrect you know look Romania I
don't know what their system is like I
don't know whether they're corrupt I've
heard things but I don't know I don't
have any real information so I'd be
talking out of my ass to say
you know if he really did like sex
traffic people if you really did all the
things he's saying well I hope that gets
proven in court and I I hope he gets
punished if he really did that if he
didn't do that I hope he gets exonerated
and I hope he gets the [ __ ] out of
Romania I don't know I don't know what
he did I know a lot of what he does is
theater right a lot of what he does is
very like satire he he plays the role of
this boastful misogynist who smokes
cigars and drives Lamborghinis and
that's his thing and because of that
he's amassed an amazing amount of money
and he's done it by doing this
character's online persona but then also
says very wise things he says ridiculous
[ __ ] but also says really interesting
things he's a very smart guy if you live
listen to him being interviewed by
Patrick Bet David Patrick Bet David
interviewed him after he got canceled
off of all social media and Patrick is
fantastic he's really good at letting
people talk and talking to everybody and
Patrick is so wealthy and so successful
outside of the world of podcasting that
he don't only does it because he's
interested in it and so he's the perfect
guy to handle that because he does not
afraid of talk to talk to anybody he'll
talk to anybody
and so he had him on for a long-form
conversation they talked for hours and
you get to see this is a very
intelligent and calculated guy you might
not agree with his message you might not
agree with all the misogynist stuff you
might not agree with and I don't agree
with it you might not agree with all the
the crazy Antics but you cannot deny
that that's been incredibly successful
because it resonates with a lot of young
men who don't feel represented in the
media and they see this guy and it looks
like fun do they agree with what he's
saying that doesn't mean they agree with
it they think it's fun it's like pro
wrestling he's like a bad guy in pro
wrestling he's a heel he's smoking
cigars with his Lamborghinis and see
that's where I go I go
I think there's probably a lot of people
think that and then I think there's
probably other people who take it
seriously which is where that's where
it's a super that is where it gets
[ __ ] up where it gets [ __ ] up is
like young boys repeating the [ __ ] that
he's saying to young girls because I
mean he says they're they're supposed to
property and he owns them which is nuts
and so you hope people are like oh
that's an act the one thing I will say
for an intelligent guy which I agree
with you he is
to be doing the things he's being
accused of doing and then go seek
publicity
is a very unwise move if he's did the
thing correct he did then then it's like
what you would think if you're
committing atrocities you would try to
stay under the radar he does quite the
opposite yeah but but again we don't
know no nobody knows that's the problem
is that's like the pizza thing the pizza
box I don't know if you saw that
everybody saying he got busted because
of the pizza box and then the author is
like that nothing to do with no they
knew he was in Romania it was just
what's that word schadenfrog shot and
fruit shot and fruit that's been what it
was like he's making fun of Greta
thornberg and then he gets [ __ ]
arrested right afterwards it's kind of
hilarious yeah the way it happens it
like people said it's the biggest like
self self third biggest tweet or retweet
it was Greta I mean it was yeah it was
okay it's kind of funny when she said
that's what happens you don't recycle it
that was yeah that was good Chad that
shit's hilarious you got to give it to
her look and also like why are you going
after some 19 year old autism like
figure out whether that was provoked
like he just did that out of the blue
yeah he's just talking [ __ ] but now
again that move from somebody who's been
accused of sex trafficking I think rape
was thrown in there and then you're out
there being like look at me look at me
crazy again but what you said nailed it
nobody else I yeah I think the latest
thing that they're saying is
um tax evasion right isn't that what I'm
saying I'll be honest with you I was
Googling them now I just found an
exclusive story on Vice
that says the reason he was kicked off
of big brother is not the reason that
was publicly known or what was thought
of it says that he was arrested for
suspicion of rape in 2015.
he was uh investigated over allegations
of sexual assault and physical abuse in
the UK during which time he appeared on
Big Brother for five days let's just
post a little bit ago UK authorities
declined to prosecute
that says that he would they uh told the
producers of the show like five days
before he was kicked off and then a
video was found of him
uh and a girl doing something that then
they came out and said this was like a
kinky video they were making and
everyone thought the girl came out and
said that that was very consensual and
that they were doing role play and that
they like to do this thing where he
would like beat her up or startup was
saying that didn't have anything to do
with wise this is one of the parts I
don't know this is one of the perfect
examples though kind of what we're
talking about or I like I don't [ __ ]
believe Vice I don't know I don't
believe how can you believe anything
that is said about somebody so
controversial because everybody
seemingly has already made up their mind
right so where to get real information
on him who knows all the objectionable
stuff I think also was unnecessary I
think if he want I mean I don't know him
if I did know him I would tell him all
the the boastful [ __ ] and the the [ __ ]
about him being you know the top G and
all that stuff all that shit's great but
the misogynistic stuff like if you have
daughters or if you have a wife or if
you have sisters and stuff like that you
don't want that well you know that that
that narrative like putting that out
there that's negative to everybody it's
not it's not even positive to him it's
like it's not necessary we had him on
one of our podcasts and he almost struck
me exactly how you said like for let's
say he's talking for 10 minutes I'm like
oh making sense smart and then he says
something so wild over the top literally
like women on my property like I own
them it's like whoa what'd you just say
and that's what he does but yeah he's
also selling that class it what is the
class it Hustlers University what is
that what it's like using people to
hustle but what do they are they I don't
know the hustle they can quit it anytime
they want it's like 70 bucks a month
then you become a top G
that's literally I mean is that bad I
don't know I mean is it is it a con game
or is it is he trying to give them
legitimate information what is he giving
him other than what he's already said in
interviews and and like what how's it a
university like what is he has people
who and that's where it's a grayer
because I aren't there like professors
Hustlers University experience modern
wealth creation I haven't looked at this
I didn't know this was even real yeah no
this is what he said like amazing so
many grifters main business secure your
spot for just 49 is your last chance to
secure a spot or a discounted price this
weird countdown thing is oh that's
hilarious it's just recycle one hour 10
minutes and 36 seconds to sign up and
that's gonna be 147. enroll now Jamie
you have only an hour before this class
let's enroll listen roll what do we have
to do click on that enroll now okay what
do we have to do the real world has
launched a completely Matrix independent
platform where we teach you how to make
money in the digital age how do they
teach you how to make money
she's just hustle man you just hustle so
600 bucks a year it's also another thing
like this Matrix thing which he has
which again I
I
am a firm believer based on my
experience like people are out to get
you they're out to get you he also if he
committed these crimes he's sort of
brilliant be like they're coming for me
in the next couple days because you know
they're coming and then your apology aha
he was right it's like a self-fulfilling
prop who knows right but I will say
he goes too far like and yeah
you'd think rational people be like whoa
you're crazy but there's a lot of you
know and that's where anything's a
slippery he's also a wild dude that
lives in the world of kickboxing and
that that is a wild group of people I
mean you pay attention to like Top
Flight kickboxers like the botter
Harries and the I mean there's some
Melvin manhole if there's some wild
[ __ ] people in that world that is a
crazy world where there's not a lot of
money and you're facing [ __ ] straight
up killers and you know I mean there's
all sorts of different personalities in
that world but it's a different kind of
human they're digital's wild masculine
very aggressive people you know and
that's that's part of his shtick but he
if you want to use the word toxic
masculinity he's he's it that well the
the bad stuff that he said embodies that
yes yeah yeah and that's what people are
that's why people are rooting for what
he said to be true because they don't
want that right but you're still crazy
to root for that because you're not
thinking about the victims that would be
you're basically
that means a lot of people were hurt
well it means if it's true you want them
to be punished correct like hoping that
it's not true when it is true is not
good either
no but you know what I'm saying like if
you're hoping that it's true and it's
not true that's horrible because you are
hoping for people to have been
victimized I see what you're saying yes
right yeah I mean you should never hope
violent crimes are committed right
absolutely agreed yeah for sure but you
also hope that he's not accused of these
things when it's just because of his
bombastic totality and talking [ __ ] and
getting all this attention which he
clearly has done you got to wonder how
much of it is set like when you talk to
Piers Morgan that was a very interesting
conversation because Pierce confronted
him on all these things and he did a
great job of explaining what he does and
why he does it and and you know it's
like the guy went viral in a way that no
one has and so quickly yeah in a while
we're like my 12 year old and my 14 year
old were asking me about it yeah no he
he was it yeah all over Tick Tock and
all over everything and and if you just
look at some scary part in a weird way
if you're 12 year old than 14 year olds
are hearing some uh right the outrage
like nobody wants yeah
yeah he didn't even have a tick tock I
think and he was like the number one guy
on Tick Tock crazy
I think they probably banned him right I
mean they banned them from everything
they banned them from Facebook
yeah Elon brought him back yeah which
listen I agree with I think you should
be able I don't think Banning people's
the way I think this exchange with Greta
thurnberg is a perfect example of how to
counteract that yeah like she just mocks
him and and then he gets arrested and
she has the [ __ ] tweet of the year
making fun of his arrest yeah and a
[ __ ] perfect one-liner that's what
happens is you don't recycle your pizza
box yeah right it's a genius that's why
it's good that someone like that is on
social media because you get you get a
chance for people to participate in the
conversation